To be honest, it's a good idea to visit the community first,
especially if you're ready inside Canada,
visit the community and see if you can actually live in a rural,
a remote area in Canada.
This is coming from someone who is living in a small town
and remote area here in Canada
because this town or the
the way we live here is not actually for everyone.
So if you have, you know,
like time, spare time to visit your perspective community,
I would highly, highly suggest that you do that.
You can actually check those videos that I posted already
showing my life here, what it's like living in a small town in Canada
because this is important factor that you really have to double check
even before you move here.
Because again, if you're someone who wants to,
you know, live in a big city,
then probably you really have to check
if you wanted to move to a rural area.